juan construyó un corral rectangular de
21 pies de largo cuyo perímetro es de 78
pies cual es el ancho del corral de juan
hagamos entonces un dibujo de cómo se
vería el corral de juana voy a hacer lo
mejor posible un rectángulo esta sería
una vista aérea del corral rectangular
de juan ahí lo tenemos y nos dicen que
mide de largo 21 pies así es que esta
distancia es de 21 pies y si esta
distancia mide 21 pies entonces esta
distancia de aquí también mide 21 pies
también nos dicen que el perímetro es de
78 pies así es que el perímetro es 78
pies 78 pies necesitamos calcular el
ancho
el ancho va a ser esta distancia de aquí
esta distancia de aquí es el ancho que
también corresponde a esta distancia de
aquí ese es el ancho del corral pero
sabemos cómo calcular el perímetro de un
rectángulo
estos 21 pies con esta distancia de aquí
con estos 21 pies de aquí con esta
distancia de aquí vamos a obtener los 78
pies del perímetro así es que una manera
de encontrar el ancho es decir bueno si
sumamos todos estos lados vamos a
obtener 78 restemos de 78 lo que miden
estos dos lados
estos dos lados color naranja que miden
21 pies para al restar los de 78 obtener
lo que miden estos dos lados
correspondientes al ancho del corral
hagamos entonces esa resta 78 menos 21 y
menos 21 esto es 78 menos 42 y eso
cuánto nos da 78 menos 42 lo voy a hacer
por acá no quiero cometer un error por
descuido 78 menos 42 es igual a 36 así
es que esto es igual a 36 y recordemos
lo que representan estos 36 pies esos 36
pies corresponden a la suma de los
anchos la suma del ancho aquí y la suma
del ancho aquí pero sabemos que estos
dos lados miden lo mismo que esta
distancia es igual
esta otra distancia y que al sumarlas
nos da 36 entonces ahora tenemos que
encontrar cuál es ese número que si lo
sumamos con sí mismo nos da 36 bien
sabemos que 18 18 nos da 36 18 más 18 es
igual a 36 así es que este lado de aquí
tiene que medir 18 y este lado de aquí
también mide 18 y podemos comprobar esto
sumando estos cuatro números hagámoslo
tenemos 18 18 los dos anchos más los dos
largos 21 más 21 y esto no resulta 36
fue lo que obtuvimos aquí que era lo que
necesitábamos que los dos anchos sumarán
más 42
42 y eso nos da igual a 36 42 es igual a
78 el perímetro del corral